let's go next to tyler from lubbock
texas
tyler from lubbock texas here on the air
hey david how do you hear me
doing well so
i know in texas we have a lot of people
who are very open to progressive ideas
like ubi
like medicare for all and many others
but a lot of those same voters they
either don't vote or they have a
republican
that's one major issue currently in the
united states which is gun control
so my question is would it be considered
a good strategy move
to tone down the gun control
language like instead of saying we want
to ban certain types of guns maybe say
maybe just only push the universal
background checks
in order to get these types of voters in
order to vote more democratically or
more liberally so the answer is yes
if it made a difference but the problem
is either way republicans claim that
democrats are coming from your guns i
mean the joe biden campaign's a great
example
joe biden barely talked about guns and
yet
trump campaigned on he's going to take
all your guns
the second amendment's going to go away
so like what you're saying makes perfect
sense and i've spoken to bill share
about this in fact which is that
the gun issue is a voting issue much
more for people on the right
than it is for people on the left but
the problem is
even if a democratic candidate said the
only thing i want to do is background
checks republicans will still say
they're coming for your guns so then
it's like does it even really matter
what they say
that's true but also there's been times
where you know we
we've had joe biden say oh i'm looking
forward i'm looking
to get another assault weapons ban and
you know most gun owners including
myself
we see that and we think well i mean an
assault weapons ban is only really an
appearance ban rather than
in you know in a uh functional band
so we we see that and we think
it's kind of questionable whether we
want to vote for joe biden i mean i did
yeah i don't know about many other
people but
that's so for someone like you when you
say it's an appearance ban
if there was a ban on assault weapons
how would it affect your life
i mostly collect firearms based off of
you know
this was in military service at some
point okay so i'm a collector and
and as far as for me they would
inhibit my ability to collect what's a
what's an
antique gun you would not be able to
collect if there were an assault weapon
weapons ban well i don't i don't
i don't just do antique nt weapons okay
but
for example technically an m14
style firearm if you change out the
stock and add
like a scope on it that that would could
characterize it as an assault weapons
so you're saying so basically even with
an assault weapons ban
as long as you didn't change the stock
and put a scope on it you still would be
able to collect that gun is that what
you're saying
no because that firearm also has a
bayonet lug
okay so that that's but this is now a
third thing i guess what it sounds it
sounds like
it sounds like it wouldn't even really
affect you very much even if there were
an assault weapons ban
which it doesn't look like there's going
to be so i guess i'm just wondering like
is it maybe the voters who are
overstating
the relevance of something like an
assault weapons ban i'm just thinking
out loud here you know
ah that's actually that's a fair point
actually i didn't think about that
seems it would do very little even if
there was an assault weapons ban for you
yeah probably but i like suck a few of
the firearms i have if there was to be a
soul with this ban would be
considered pre-banned firearms and we
could consider the 1990s
assault weapons ban right which which i
could still have but i will be able to
purchase
parts for or you know buy it again so it
would very
very in a very minor way it would impact
your life
if ever if at random enough yes it would
impact my life but otherwise wow
all right okay good all right well i i
appreciate the question i think it's a
good topic which is if there's an issue
that is
that that is not necessarily a voting
issue even for people on the left but
it'll turn off people on the right
maybe from a strategic standpoint you
downplay that issue
it's not an illegitimate question and
check out my interviews with bill
shareware we've talked about voting
issues before
all right all right my friend thank you
very much you may not have known this
but when you see me sitting here on the
show i am often wearing shirts by a
company called teddy stratford
i asked them to be a sponsor because
they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman
at checkout